are you fully like aware of like how
much of a classic album please excuse me
for being anti-socialist like are you
aware of like how almost like god damn
perfect that project was like or is it
is it just for you it's like hey it did
what it was supposed to do on to the
next
yeah that's how i look at it i feel like
[ __ ] it's just what it is
and ain't no you know it's glory in it i
love it it's a great album i can still
listen to it to this day and that's what
the music is really about i feel like
that's what all your projects used to
strive for all your projects to be that
like
can i still listen to this album year
after year and time at the time that's
what we shoot for yeah i feel like uh
i haven't seen a project
carry
for as long as that album did i feel
like it felt like it was like a two-year
run like we was man here at the radio
station we was playing god damn
the box in high fashion and power
rotation damn near two years after the
[ __ ] ball and i know balls are on
that album but ballin still is in power
rotation like every three weeks here at
real ninety two three it's like it's
crazy bro like like your records
research in a way that is like not
normal
to like a radio audience it's [ __ ]
far it's it's it's special man that's
fine i appreciate all the people
listening and you know y'all hold me
down with this [ __ ] you know i'm sure so
i appreciate everybody that's involved
with that and
like i said bro i just make the music
that i want to hear a lot of the time so
that's why sometimes they change and we
go through our different phases in life
and [ __ ] and it's cool like
you know that's it's a lifestyle that's
why i'm pushing like it's more of a
lifestyle for me it's not
i'm trying to make this song be this
like that's why i feel like my music is
separated from a lot of other people
because i just make it based on where
i'm at um uh you kicked off the second
album sampling the kanye [ __ ] which was
cinematic as [ __ ] yeah great way to kick
that project that [ __ ] was that [ __ ]
game i was like oh man that [ __ ] had me
[ __ ] absolutely i remember i went and
watched the new spider-man movie because
it came out do you remember the new
spider-man movie you dropped the same
day your album yeah i got out from
spider-man i threw that [ __ ] on i was
like whoa yeah
um
did you like get your i mean obviously
you and kanye have had a very well
documented friendship over the last
couple of years uh you being on donda um
but was that something that you like
played for him let him know like hey you
know i kind of brought this joint back i
had um told him the idea but i feel like
in that time and space i didn't get the
when i got it fully done i didn't get
the chance to play it before i'm fully
done rick ross somehow
he's in my top ten but he's some somehow
underrated still i don't know how it is
when we think of like the all-time
greats i feel like not enough people say
his [ __ ] name yeah like
him he's himself like
ross if it wasn't for ross you know it
just
i felt like he held the streets down for
for a good minute and you feel me it's
just like that was his vibe and
he was just different and
maybach music [ __ ] like that's why i
bought my maybach i seen nip have his
maybach and rick ross making the maybach
music when i was young before nip had
maybe it was like when he did the
maybach music it was more so like
what is a maybach like what is that
yo that run what he had obviously
there's like deeper than rap but then
teflon dawn and the mmg project
self-made one and two
[ __ ] and shout out to gunplay who's also
underrated gunplay is a [ __ ] beast
man